bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors les libanais
qui sont toujours dans l'attenté de
savoir ce qui s'est passé à beyrouth
l'année dernière le 4 août de l'année
dernière avec l'explosion cette double
explosion
cette séance parlementaire qui risque
d'être bousculé avec ce boycott des
députés ce que finalement c'est un moyen
de ralentir l'enquète
voilà sur 7 sur ce drame
écoutez je me permets de rappeler à tous
les téléspectateurs qu'aujourd'hui
l'explosion du 4 août ou 2020 a été la
troisième plus grande explosion dans le
monde
une explosion que nous appelons au liban
une explosion criminelle une explosion
terroriste une explosion de nitrate
d'ammonium a été importée au liban par
des mains de vie bas n'est que dont une
partie a été exporté du liban à travers
aussi des libanais et bien été explosé
au liban et dont il a fait plus que de
120 victimes aujourd'hui on appelle une
explosion criminelle est aujourd'hui
notre blessure est beaucoup plus
profonde du premier jour au premier jour
on ne comprenait pas ce qui se passait
mais après 368 jours exactement
aujourd'hui on est de deux ans plus
meurtri parce que finalement les
criminels sont jusqu'à aujourd'hui
impuni on n'a pas eu la vérité de ce qui
s'est passé nous écoutons à travers
certaines enquêtes journalistiques de ce
qui se passe mais ont jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il n'y a rien d'officiel
vous dite raisonnée j'espère vraiment
que l'on puisse connaître la vérité mais
il faut bien savoir que le juge est le
coupable sont sur le même bord
aujourd'hui toute la classe politique
est directement responsable de cette
double explosion de ça de façon directe
ou indirecte
quand je lui dirai qu'il ya sûrement des
responsables qui savent et ont
finalement perpétré ce crime et d'autres
qui ont fermé les yeux tommy la tête
dans le sable pour ne pas savoir pour
des raisons politiques pour des raisons
sectaire ou pour des raisons régionales
donc aujourd'hui toute une classe
politique est directement responsable ou
indirectement responsable c'est
impossible que le juge est le coupable
soit sur le même temps aujourd'hui il ya
certains juste essaye de faire leur
travail finalement mais on peut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui il faut que je suis un
support un support local qui n'existe
pas un support régional qui à mon avis a
d'autres d'autres priorités on est
obligé d'avoir un support international
sinon on ne sera pas vérité et à savoir
qu'après l'explosion le président de la
république le chef
de l'exécutif avait promis 5 jours d
enquête pour savoir la vérité après 368
jours jusqu'à aujourd'hui on n'a aucune
résultats donc je peux vous dire que le
parlement se réunisse ou pas il enlève
finalement qu'il accuse des députés ou
pas ce n'est tout simplement pour gagner
du temps et on n'a pas confiance
malheureusement sera pouvoir judiciaire
qui est totalement politisé et aux mains
de nos politiques sont tous cas les
libanais qui se mobilisent un grand
rassemblement d'ailleurs est prévue
aujourd'hui devant le palais de l'unesco
là où doit avoir lieu cette séance
parlementaire
le liban qui depuis cette ce drame du
4-août 2020 est plongé dans une crise
sans précédent crise politique crise
économique aussi hier
on a appris que la banque du liban et
bien ce serait de subventionner à partir
donc d'aujourd'hui l'importation du
carburant au taux du dollar officiel une
mesure qui risque de provoquer une
flambée des prix alors que actuellement
on sait que déjà la situation est très
difficile on a vu des émeutes hier à
tripoli est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
voilà à d'autres manifestations ailleurs
dans le pays
écoutez comme vous le dites si bien le
liban vit aujourd'hui sa pire crise
économique sociale politique je dirais
même sécuritaire il n'a jamais vécu de
son histoire ce n'est même pas
comparable aux années de guerre où il y
avait quand même des flux de capitaux
aujourd'hui une crise dramatique sans
précédent aujourd'hui c'est une crise
finalement délibéré il faut savoir c'est
délibéré ce n'est pas qui est simplement
économique sécurisé délibéré on voit
tous les jours une attaque sur tous les
secteurs productifs du pays une attaque
qui a commencé sur un secteur bancaire
et financier quelles que soient les
responsabilités
une attaque qui était suivi sur tous les
secteurs productifs comme le secteur
commercial industriel pharmaceutique
hospitalier et on peut dire très bien
organisé et perpétré avec un spread est
une stratégie destructrice aujourd'hui
tous nos ministères sont gelés et vous
vous n'allez surtout les ministères bas
sur les militaires qui travaillent vous
n'avez pas de courant pas de carburant
et même les employés ne peuvent pas
arriver même à leur travail jeudi même
sur des secteurs publics par manque
d'essence aujourd'hui notre crise je dis
bien délibéré parce que les grands
points vous parler aujourd'hui de la
crise d'essence et autres sons avec une
responsabilité totale de l'état et sur
une crise interne aujourd'hui si on n'a
pas de l'essence quand vous voyez à
l'écran aujourd'hui ce n'est pas parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'essence que la plus
grande partie du carburant du liban est
pas et sort en contrebande en dehors du
pays sur des pays voisins si aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas de médicaments c'est
pas parce qu'on n'a pas de stop c'est
parce que l'état libanais n'a pas payé
plus que 700 millions de dollars aux
sociétés productrices international donc
aujourd'hui on a un état qui est
directement responsable
mais aujourd'hui qui ferment mont-joli
dans un service dont on parle d' émeutes
on parle de subventions mais en même
temps on ne peut pas continuer à
subventionner quand il n'ya plus de
devises étrangères dans le pays et les
villes étrangères dans le pays on sent
qu ont complètement disparu parce que
les trois sources de devises ont été
complètement détruites la première c'est
les devises qui venait par mois expatrié
à savoir entre 6 et 8 millions rubis
milliards de dollars qui ont
complètement disparu après que les
expatriés ont vu leurs avoirs au niveau
complètement gelé pour ne pas dire
pris par un état libanais qui les a
dépensé la deuxième c'était le support
qu'ils venaient des instances
internationales
ils vont plus faire aucun financement ce
qui était normal parce que l'argent a
été décapité dans une corruption
galopante au liban et le troisième
certaines économies d'un tourisme autre
qui est impossible de venir donc
finalement quand on a une offre en
devises qui tombe et on a une demande
qui est sur une toute une population non
seulement d'ibanez mais on sait capter
l'implémentation de lacs de césar en
série donc nous savons que le régime
syrien ou même des digues d'économie
syriens peuvent venir prendre certains
de la liquidité qui se passe au liban
donc on a une crise une pénurie de
liquidités c'est normal puisque plus
subventionnée mais finalement ce n'est
pas vraiment là le problème le gros
problème c'est le manque de gestion de
l'état qui a été de pire état au monde à
créer la crise atypique dans le monde
mais a été le pire dans la gestion de
crise et jusqu'à maintenant on a pu
voter aucune loi n'a pu quant à
commencer sur un audit qui a été promis
internationale qui n'a pas été fait
l'état libanais jusqu'à aujourd'hui n'a
pas pu mettre une loi sur le contrôle de
capitaux et j'en passe merci beaucoup en
tout cas fois drôle d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise
libanais dans le monde